german political leaders meet today to
kick off the fractious process of
coalition talks after the central left
social democrats won a narrow victory in
this weekend's election party leader
olaf schultz is insisting he will be
able to form a governing coalition with
two smaller parties but angela merkel's
conservatives who came in a close second
are also arguing that they have a
mandate to form a new government
that puts the spotlight on the green
party and the free democrats as germany
enters what could be months of coalition
negotiations
after a tight race the final results
brought clarity
all of schultz and his social democrats
edging a small but definite lead over
the conservatives
it's a breathtaking turn around for a
party that only a few months ago many
had written off
but the sbd won't be able to govern
alone their leader made it clear who his
favorite partners would be
[Applause]
the voters made it very clear they told
us that we should form the government
they strengthened three parties the
social democrats the greens and the fdp
and that is the obvious mandate by
voters that these three parties should
lead the next government
the social democrats won't be the only
party trying to win allies
despite leading the conservative party
of outgoing chancellor anger merkel to
their worst ever result the cdu
chancellor candidate amin lashed didn't
concede his party's right to govern
clarence no party can derive a mandate
to govern from this result
that also applies to the spd
the election campaign is now over and no
one can act as though they alone can
decide who will form a government
and that's why talks with potential
partners are now necessary
but it looks as though the conservatives
won't be getting first dibs in such
talks with the two smaller parties
in their post-election press conference
the greens co-leaders indicated that it
would be the social democrats they would
turn to first
keep this i know
there's a certain logic to talking to
the spd and the fdp now that doesn't
mean that we rule out talking to the
conservatives
the other would-be king makers the
business-friendly fdp even went as fast
to suggest that they would speak to the
greens before approaching either of the
two main parties
whatever the outcome of the coalition
talks it looks like the new government
in berlin will be made up of three
parties
an arrangement that germany hasn't seen
in more than half a century
after the last general election four
years ago negotiations dragged on for
over four months
schultz promised that with him in charge
there would be a speedier resolution
my idea is
that we will be very fast in getting a
result for this government and it should
be before christmas if possible
until then angela merkel will continue
to hold the fort her time in office
extends until a new chancellor is ready
to take over
so the coalition building starts now
let's take a look at how that process
normally works the party with the
highest vote share in this case the espd
usually takes a first shot at putting
together a government they'll hold talks
with their potential coalition partners
the greens and the fdp and if there's
enough common ground they'll draw up a
coalition agreement
the haggling can take months after the
last election germany had to wait
171 days for a new government if
coalition talks between all the parties
fail there are two options you can form
a minority government or hold fresh
elections
chancellor mackel will stay in office as
a caretaker in a caretaker capacity
until a new government is formed
well for the very latest let's bring in
dw correspondent julia saudelli uh julia
spd leader olaf scholz he says he is
going to form a new government that he
has a mandate for that and that he hopes
he can get a coalition together by
christmas but how certain is it that the
social democrats will actually lead the
next government
well in politics as in life nothing is
certain but it looks like at the moment
the social democrats are let's say in
the lead in terms of looking of
looking at forming a new a new
government and that is something that
also resonates with german voters some
polls have shown that a majority of
germans want a three-way coalition
between the spd the greens and the free
democrats fdp and it looks like this is
what's going to happen we have
heard here
members of the spd saying they're ready
to start going into talks already this
week if the other two parties say
they're ready so they're looking to get
started on these talks but anything can
happen we've seen it happen before
coalition talks collapsing so even
though it looks like the spd will have a
first dibs at trying to start a
coalition it doesn't necessarily mean
that they'll be able to form one
successfully
okay so while the social democrats are
trying to do that you've got the cdu on
the other hand chancellor mackel's party
in this case led by armen lashed he's
even though
they did not win the election this time
he says he will still try to form a
government too how realistic is that
well a lot of that depends on how much
amin lashed manages to um maintain his
uh his standing in the party we've heard
uh some disgruntled comments within uh
the parties some members calling for
lashed to resign others saying that they
really don't see a mandate to form a
government and that the ceu should do
some soul searching before they decide
to take lead again
but amin lashit seems determined to hold
on to the hope and possibility and he
said he he is available and as we've
said um the coalition talks between the
other parties could collapse and then
the cdu could eventually uh play a role
in terms of possibly forming a
government if these talks between the
spd the greens and the fdp do fail
okay but the first step we've got the
social democrats talking to the probably
the greek the greens and the fdp trying
to put together a three-way coalition
what are the main challenges julia to
forming that coalition
well between the social democrats and
the greens there are some closer points
of contact in terms of party programs
the two parties had said before
the election and had said that again
that they were happy to uh possibly
govern together and now the uh the joker
fdp has come into play and um
this complicates the situation a little
bit because in terms of
red lines for example the free democrats
have said that one of their red lines as
is that they don't want to see tax
increases while the other two parties
had put forward the idea of maybe
increasing taxes for the richer part of
the population for example for the
greens to finance ambitious climate
goals
also in terms of climate goals the fdp
has slightly a different approach
especially compared to the greens so
there are some points there that are
going to have to be clarified it's going
to be all about compromise and
finding
common points that the three parties can
agree on
julia thank you so much our political
correspondent julia saudelli there at
the german rights time
well as we just heard it looks
increasingly likely that one of the
biggest obstacles to forging a new
governing coalition here in germany will
be squaring the parties different
positions on tackling climate change the
free democrats and the greens both agree
it's an urgent problem but they have
very different ideas about how to fix it
tens of thousands on the streets of
berlin
aiming to put climate front and center
of the next german government
with a helping hand by an activist
superstar
we want change
we demand change
and we are the change
what exactly change means depends on
which party you speak to
for the greens devastating floods in the
summer were evidence of the crisis they
had long warned about
to fix it they want a ban on new
combustion car engines speed limits
massive rail investment and to speed up
the exit from coal
we finally need a government that will
fight for the climate with all its might
with all its heart and with passion
for the free democrats you could
substitute climate with business
the only things they want to ban are tax
rises and spending splurges
they're counting on innovation and the
market to solve the problem
[Applause]
our responsibility is to produce the
technologies that make it happen
at home but also in the world
an economic perspective a free way of
life reconciled with climate protection
little separates the two biggest parties
all of schultz's social democrats and
armen lashed christian democrats promise
to hit net zero carbon dioxide emissions
by 2045
and exit coal in 2038
for them the message is that the scale
of the upheaval requires careful
management
[Music]
we will only be able to tackle the big
tasks such as the energy transition or
the climate turnaround with growth and
new economic dynamics which will require
a lot of resources
it's the biggest industrial and economic
modernisation project that germany has
had to undertake in well over 100 years
we want to tackle this and we can do it
if we start now
again as the horse trading begins in
berlin
the question for the parties is where
are they willing to budge
well for more let's speak with lisa
bardum she's the climate policy
spokesperson for the greens in the
german parliament thanks for being with
us ms bottom if your party does enter
government it will be as a junior
partner in a three-way coalition what
makes you think you can push through
your climate agenda in those
negotiations with other parties who have
different ideas about how to address the
climate crisis
good morning first of all
what we've seen with the election is a
clear mandate for attacking the climate
crisis we gained nearly six percent and
our main topic
was
climate protection and especially the
young younger generation they voted for
us
so people below 30 um they had greens at
the first place
so i think um it's quite clear that this
topic gains percentages and um
yeah people want something to go forward
whereas the conservatives
they lost this election so
for me the direction is quite clear
okay but you really haven't addressed
how you're going to overcome the
differences with the other parties in
coalition negotiations just a few days
ago you were tweeting about
how inadequate other parties in germany
are on climate policy you posted a
picture of olaf schultz whose spd is
first in line to lead the next
government you accused him of climate
failures as a policy maker
is your party willing and indeed able to
work under a leader you describe as a
failure in addressing your top priority
that's true we had a failure in climate
politics
in the last years of the great the grand
coalition i mean that's why i wanted to
have a change that's why we did a
campaign for the election and that's why
the greens are so important in
government
and every party i mean except the fd
addressed the topic of climate
protection so every party has to deliver
now if it's sbd or ftp or
wherever party
and i think uh i think we're open for
any proposals how to reduce co2 but we
have to have proposal and it's not
enough to have some rhetoric so um
we're ready to talk with the other
parties and
but we can't do it in public of course
we can do it in in the media
what are your
non-negotiables moving into this if your
party well here link put it another way
is your party prepared to walk out of
coalition talks if you feel you're not
getting your agenda across
i think it's quite clear
that we have to phase out coal earlier
and that we have to increase the
percentage of renewable energies because
um yeah we cannot
get we cannot reach our goals without
that and i think the red line should be
the german climate targets we all
um agree to them in in the bundestag so
we should adjust to that
lisa bottom member of the german
parliament from the green party thank
you very much
thank you
well for the conservative cdu csu block
this election delivered the worst ever
national result several prominent
christian democrats lost in their
constituencies without angela meckel
leading the charge the party's most
important driving force was missing
something that was very clear in
mackel's own constituency
parliamentary constituency 15 covers a
picturesque corner of germany the island
of rugen and the city of greifsbelt on
the baltic coast
this was merkel country angela merkel
held the seat as the directly elected
member of the bundestag at every
election since 1990 but sunday's vote
changed all that to replace the cdu
chancellor the voters here have chosen a
left-wing social democrat
everything that has been around for a
while wears out at some point and if the
things you want to change don't change
eventually you try
i think that things will be fine with
the spd and after all they will
certainly not govern alone that's why i
believe the fact that the cdu lost here
is definitely very good for young people
the whole conservative campaign didn't
speak to me
schultz was much more effective
merkel was in the constituency just a
week ago at a rain-soaked campaign event
with cdu leader amin lashette the
chancellor was hoping her popularity
would boost georg gunter the christian
democrat aiming to succeed her in this
seat but what if she had decided to
stand herself
she can't believe hers first
i can well imagine that she would have
won more votes than the cdu did in fact
get there might have been a kind of
strategic approach by voters to elect a
powerful woman in the hope that our area
will be represented accordingly but on
the other hand there's a clear move
we've had enough
now we want something different
the lack of enthusiasm for the
conservatives here is not an isolated
case across a huge swathe of germany
many formerly cdu seats were flipped by
the spd
as well as a massive drop in their share
of the overall vote these losses are a
further sign merkel's party needs to
rethink its appeal
now that the chancellor herself is
departing from the scene
you